[Music]
[Music]
this for me is a dream and not not just
speaking at jsconf uh this is my first
disconf but um
type javascript it's it's it's a it's a
real dream for me and and somehow i find
i found myself
in the midst of this amazing amazing
proposal is one of the authors the one
of the co-authors so really it's a dream
for me and it's it's great to to be here
and talk to you about it so let's let's
start
for me what where what are the three
biggest trends in javascript for the
last 10 years oh by the way i'm 35 years
tetris not not 30 years
[Music]
there we go
uh
three biggest trends in javascript
development and i've been there
since 95. uh for me it's modern ui
frameworks like react angular view etc
javascript tooling the bundlers that
type the linters the minifiers there's a
whole ecosystem that helps javascript
and third and it's amazing it's an
amazing trend which is typescript the
way typescript has evolved and and and
made itself a huge part of the ecosystem
and this talk is about a formal proposal
for enhancing javascript
that will change forever the way we view
typescript the way we do javascript
tooling and the way modern ui frameworks
will will work really this i think this
proposal if it will be accepted and i'm
going to stop saying if it will be
accepted because in my heart i know it
will be
but if if it will be accepted it will
change the javascript landscape forever
really i i believe it so
what a proposal it's a proposal for
adding types to javascript which which
is
amazing because javascript uh so who am
i
uh guilt i are as i said i go all the
way back to the 80s i'm not a boomer i'm
gen x
i i on the other hand i love to code i
still do it i tried the whole management
thing didn't work for me um still a
developer still writing code to this day
i'm currently an architect at ron forest
an architect as in you know a senior
developer who's way past his age and is
still developing so you can't call him a
developer you just call him an architect
but
i am also a member of the group that is
writing this proposal
and and actually the original author
which is i'm still like shocked from
from the whole thing with guidance from
little dan which we who re little dan
who helped me uh write the proposal and
made made lots of notes
but while i am a group i'm a member of
the group
the opinions are my own they are not not
necessarily the opinions of the members
of this proposal we're we're a varied
group we don't always think the same now
we have people from igalia from from
google from from from microsoft
obviously from bloomberg and we don't
necessarily think the same so it's
definitely my opinions take them with a
grain of salt uh and lastly
uh they're definitely not my employers
and i do not and they asked me to add
that the typescript team are very much
uh
um
with us in in this proposal for adding
types to javascript team but i do not
speak on behalf of the typescript team
they asked me to put that
okay
the proposal is officially part of the
tc39 tc39 we'll talk about that in a
second it will get heavily shaped it
will not be as i talk about it here
there are no guarantees it will stay
like this so as i said take it with a
grain of salt this is not the final
proposal it will absolutely not be and
this talk will be about this proposal
where was it proposed what is it and why
was it proposed
okay um so it's a proposal for tc39 so
what is tc39 for people that don't know
it's a committee
for the standardization of uh i'm we'll
call it of the general purpose cost
platform vendor neutral programming
language ecmascript so basically the
standard which we call ecmascript which
is basically javascript by any other
name
is pc39 that's where all the new stuff
comes from every year the process by the
way is very transparent you can access
it in github you can see all the issues
all the proposals all the meeting notes
it's amazing there's a transcript of all
the meeting notes and probably one of
the few just reads all of them
incredibly enough and each year a new
javascript version comes out uh es2015
2016 2017 is 20 21 22 and examples of
things that were added to javascript
array act
includes async await top level weight
flat flat map and whatever that um
caramel can you bring me that bottle of
water
thank you
thank you
i'm not going to delve deeply into how
features get accepted
but it's a it's a process it's a process
that takes a lot of time stage 0 is
where we were at at march
where we thought of proposing type
javascript
or or what is called formally called
type annotations
stage one is where it was whether it's
accepted for consideration that is where
we at right now it's just yeah it sounds
interesting it's the committee saying
sounds interesting maybe it's something
that we can talk about it's not accepted
stage two is where when we get to stage
two it's the spec is almost complete
it's like ready uh this is what the
feature is going to be like and if it's
accepted we do the final tweaks for the
feature this you know finish the specs
and stage three is where it gets
implemented in at least i think two
implementations let's say v8 of chrome
and
and jsc i think it's called by webkit or
or whatever in two javascript runtimes
gets implemented checked whether it
works whether there are things that we
need to tweak and once it gets to stage
four boom it's in the um it's in this in
the in the language
so let's talk about what
what is this proposal about
first of all it was proposed to tc39 on
march 31st
accepted to stage one as we said so
let's look at some javascript code add
accepts two parameters a and b returns a
plus b very simple this is regular
javascript code
this is the same code with type
annotations if this proposal gets
accepted
then this will be
legal javascript you won't need you
would not need to transpile it it will
just be accepted you can copy paste it
into the console and it will work
you can see there the type annotations
if somebody doesn't know uh uh
there's no typescript or flow or
whatever so will this pass yes it will
pass this program will pass through
javascript
um
notice no notice an interesting thing
uh this also passes
uh it accepts uh two numbers but one the
first when i call it the first is a
string the second is a boolean will this
pass and the answer is yes because type
annotations according to this proposal
will be totally ignored by javascript
they will not the javascript runtime
will actually treat them as comments the
original proposal was called types as
comments we changed it to type
annotations because it better reflects
what we're trying to do but the original
proposal was called types as comments
the javascript will treat the type
annotations just like comments
so basically these are also legal type
annotations okay um yeah uh yes siree
these are legal whatever as long as they
conform to a certain set of rules and
we'll talk about those rules later
they're by by javascript maybe not by
typescript or maybe not by flow which is
another type system maybe not by hegel
which is a third type system which you
may have or not have heard about but
they will be accepted by the javascript
runtimes and this is called these areas
where type annotations are possible are
called the type annotation syntax space
it's a space that is reserved for type
annotations and where type indications
can be whatever they want to be as long
as they conform to a specific set of
rules
more type annotation syntax space is
like type foo equals and and after and
and and the return value as a function
those are more type annotation syntax
spaces reserved for types and
not very uh not very um
coincidental those areas are exactly the
same that are reserved by typescript for
types okay exactly the same and and and
the second and the nice thing about it
is typescript and flow flow which is the
second type system which is why also
widely used have
basically the same space type syntax
annotation spaces so it was very easy
for us as a committee to reserve those
spaces in in our proposal
um okay but just a reminder this is not
typescript this is legal uh javascript
according to the proposal
wait
so why add type annotations if they're
going to be ignored i mean what's the
whole point of that and the answer is
well javascript runtime will ignore it
but the typescript and flow and other
type checkers and visual studio and and
whatever webstorm they will not be
ignoring it they will look at the type
annotations and tell you whether there
is a problem in your types
okay so the summary of the proposal and
we will talk about the proposal more and
go into details
so
we reserve syntax space for type
annotations they are totally ignored by
runtimes but are not ignored by type
checkers third-party type checkers and
coincidentally they correspond exactly
to the same places that typescript and
flow use for types
so we announced the proposal on march
9th and the internet exploded i've never
seen i've been following proposals a lot
and there are proposals that are from
from my point of view as important like
records and tuples uh
they're going to change the way
javascript is written forever
but this explodes because everybody
wants to say something on types it's
amazing so but but the nice thing is
most of them were yes and finally and
whoo and all that
but there was lots of criticisms
and from my point of view most of the
criticism was really good it was and
we'll talk about that some of it was
unkind some of it was difficult
but hey this is the internet i i've i've
uh
tough skin
so let's talk about the why let's talk
about addressing the criticism of why
this proposal is is there and and
talking about the crit the critics and
what what what they were saying so first
of all why ad types at all let's let's
start asking the question um this is not
a trivial feature adding types to
javascript type annotations is not a
trivial feature so if it's not a trivial
feature it deserves a non-trivial answer
to i adding it's not well why not you
can't add that
and i give two graphs as an answer and
and for me they were amazing and by the
way they were part of that explosion of
the internet people pointed me to this
these statistics and it's amazing so
this is march 22 2022 the number of prs
divided by language by programming
language as you can see javascript and
typescript had obviously were the kings
of github and the kings of open source
so give a big round of applause to
javascript
notice that almost if we take javascript
and typescript there's one language
javascript which i do
obviously
have almost half of the pull requests in
github in open source were typescript
that's amazing
that i did not know that even when i
started the proposal a lot of javascript
code is actually typescript the
community has embraced typescript and
and these these are i mean these are
very very um like these are real numbers
this is not just hand waving the
javascript community is using typescript
and they're used in the field and if
they're used in the field they've
probably proved their value to the
community to all of us
let's take some uh some others the state
of javascript static typing in 2020 was
the most missed feature from javascript
by far in 2021 it was less but it's
still number one
it's still number one people want static
types people want type annotations in
javascript so a large part of the
community wants that
so is it worth the command complexity i
say absolutely if it's a feature that
the community uses and uses heavily we
should start thinking of incorporating
it into javascript
but
i i got more criticisms three more
criticism about why not to add types to
javascript and they make sense
well most of it
uh
types are difficult for beginners to
grabs that's true okay we'll talk about
that types increase the payload in web
apps i don't understand that but we'll
talk about that and i don't like types
types of site
let's start on to the first one types
are difficult for beginners to grasp
yes javascript is easier because you
don't have to think about types it's
true if you start from javascript then
adding typescript is difficult but if
you start and then and if if this
proposal is accepted in five years
everybody will be starting from types
then it may all make sense and it's not
that difficult i started from c c plus
plus java okay well i did start from
basic but let's go on that for a second
uh but i i got types most people get
types my daughter
she's 16 years old she's studying java
i'm sorry but that's what she yeah
sorry oracle um
but she's she's getting types it's not
that difficult so yeah maybe a bit and
and then this somebody's that teaches
javascript is saying something
interesting new programmers searching
for a searching for example code are
likely to find typescript and flow
examples and then wonder why it results
in an error when viewed in their
browsers so people today juniors today
are struggling because a lot of
typescript a lot of code examples are
typescript
in other words whether we want it to not
or not types annotations are everywhere
so they need to be incorporated typing
types increase the payloads in web apps
i'll just put it it's yes the program
will be bigger
in in size and bytes because there are
type annotations obviously but there are
also comments and white space you know
indentation also increases payload and
what do we do about that in production
we use what
what do we use to just to make our code
smaller
minifiers exactly and minifiers will
obviously remove the type annotations as
well so no problem
but in development time i won't pay the
price for transpiling so development
time will should be nicer and i don't
need to minify during development
and the last one is i don't like types i
know
i was there um
i i was a javascript junkie and i left
java java for javascript and it was like
oh static types are bad they're really
bad and i was like trying to convince
everybody and and i was there
but i don't care about me
i care about you i care about the
community
and the well i'm i'm i'm a type type fan
now okay but but even if i wasn't this
is not about me this is about the
community and the community wants types
and the graphs show that very well
okay
so
we want type annotations i've i've
convinced you of that uh but
there are the people say we already have
typescript
why do we need to extend javascript we
can still use tooling why not just
continue using tooling
there are three answers
language
not tooling the philosophical answer
and this is going to be getting all
mushy and we have forgotten our roots
you you you weren't born during the
roots of javascript most of you
but we have forgotten our roots in
scripting as as a we write some code we
press f5 refresh command r and boom it
works
that was how we started that is how
javascript became big as a scripting
language just like python and ruby we
have become addicted to tooling and this
is absolutely my own opinion people love
tooling i don't get it we cannot not use
it anymore i'm okay with tooling
minifires are great linters are great
but today we cannot not use it if i want
to create a react app today there's only
one way to do that and that is create
react app or any one of those template
generators i cannot
build a react app or a view app or an
angular app without oh these this
complex tooling which i do not
understand
i'm writing here junior developers are
don't understand this tooling and that's
not true senior developers today don't
understand the tooling
and it's not their fault it is not your
fault for not understanding it's very
very complex
tooling is now cargo called we used to
not to need it we don't need we there
are ways to avoid it and this proposal
is part of the way to avoid tooling
philosophical answer
we're the people that use typescript are
coding in one language typescript but
running it in another language
javascript this is unheard of in any any
language except javascript this is bad
and and we're we're reaching a fork
where typescript is going this way and
javascript is going this way and that is
not bad we need to mend the rift we need
to mend the fork bring them back
together
and there's the pragmatic answer
typescript is everywhere and because
typescript is everywhere all the tooling
needs to accommodate it it used to be
that tooling only only used to do
javascript and they don't care about
typescript but now most toolings now
they understand typescript and anytime
typescript changes they need to
to accommodate these changes and
understand these changes and that is bad
um tools need to involve with javascript
with typescript and that is not good
and it's part of the reason why
typescript today has a monopoly on types
because you can't do anywhere else
because all the the tooling is working
with typescript and this proposal
simplifies the tooling tremendously
because there will be a very simple set
of rules to ignore the type annotations
and tooling will be able to use it once
and forever
and the political answer is i believe
tc39 should be at the arena for enabling
type systems not necessarily evolving
them but enabling type systems that will
be basically in everyone's javascript
vote for in the future
okay so
convince you that types are part of the
language but
this will not enable us to standardize
types in the future because today we're
saying we're ignoring types
so if we wanted to do to standardize
some kind of type system in the future
we won't be able to because once we
ignore types that's it we can't
go back which is true because of
backwards compatibility javascript has
to be always backwards compatible so
whatever you put in uh
in the type annotation syntax space will
be ignored now and forever
but i say when the need arises if we do
want to standardize the type system we
will find a way i know p i know tc39
doesn't like pragmas and used types or
whatever
but
some kind of a way if we need to
standardize the type system will be
found
and the last thing is why stop that's
the okay if we're going to do types then
let's do it all the way why stop
ignoring them
why not fully embrace typescript why not
build a type system of our own why not
do run time checking so that you know
runtime will will throw because the
parameters are bad and why not optimize
so why not fully embrace type syntax
this is a good one
everybody is using typescript i mean
flow is used heavily and most of the
code you run in facebook is is slow
but let's say but it's typescript is the
defacto standard today why not go all
the way
one
it's still evolving and i for one want
microsoft and others to continue
evolving type systems in javascript
complex we need to research and evolve
that area and if we embrace it and put
it in tc39 that stops the evolution
on its tracks and i i don't want that i
want them to continue evolving and
checking and and making it better and
better
and if we do typescript that's it that's
typescript but if we don't that will
enable other type systems to flourish
hegel flow and probably others that will
flourish and maybe overtake typescript
one day and this is good ending the
monopoly on type systems
and typescript is huge if we want to
standardize it it'll take 20 years this
is it's so big that it will never be
standardized not really
so why not build a type system of our
own or we have one a proponent of that
sitting in the front row here um he will
be a speaker in this in this uh in this
uh
in this
conference so why not build a type
system our own let's make it simpler
typescript is so complex
and the other people say let's make it
cleaner
um typescript is so
weird so typescript is too complex let's
make it a simpler one let's make a very
simple you know accept numbers except
boolean accept an object with these
fields yeah why not that's it we don't
all need all the complexities but the
complexities of typescript are there for
a reason because typescript wants to
make it be the type system for
javascript and to have all the
javascript libraries the current ones
be typescript compatible and and tell us
for example pick pick and load we want
this to be an error
okay a pick object
pick two fields a and b dot c that
should be an error
that's not a simple type system
and basically most of what typescript is
doing is evolving towards
making all the libraries all javascript
be type compatible and it's
difficult
what about making it cleaner like
haskell or camel reason they have a very
very clean type system very very small
very nice really if you use reason or oh
camel or haskell it's like oh this is so
nice this is so small but yeah
but
we're not using haskell we're using
javascript and to be
a type system for javascript we can't
make it simpler we can't make it come
clean because of what i said earlier it
won't work
why not do runtime checking
because typescript today doesn't do any
run on time checking well it just clears
out the types it just just only does
compile time build time so uh no
checking
uh
having said that
tc39 suggested we do some check to
check this route so we will be checking
it and let's optimize based on the types
if we know that it accepts two numbers
why not optimize i don't want to get
into that there's a whole twitter thread
on that
in in the
comments okay what about the what
let's go and as i said this will undergo
considerable change uh in in the in the
future so don't take it uh
as it is
okay so let's start talking about the
syntax space what exactly will be in and
what will not be in the proposal what is
in the proposal and what is not in the
proposal first of all functions
arguments uh you have to specify the
arguments of the
of you you can specify the the type of
the argument
but that begs the question where does
the type end
how does javascript know to ignore the
types where does it
is it
does it search for the comma at the end
of the argument it can't search for the
comma because the type itself has a
comma okay so how does that work how
does it ignore in comments it ignores
because it searches for the star slash
but here how does it ignore and the
answer we've come up with and again it
may change um
we do search for the comma kinda
but if there's a if there's a bracket
like a parentheses or a square bracket
or an angle bracket or uh whatever it's
called
um then we start counting and and and
balancing the parentheses okay and
whatever is inside those parentheses we
just ignore it
so that's the current proposal of how we
ignore types at runtime we look for
whatever is needs to be at the end but
we look if we find some parentheses then
we start counting and balancing them and
ignoring whatever is in the middle
and this will allow continued evolution
of type annotations without breaking
javascript compatibility so typescript
and flow and hegel and others will be
able to play in this space
and some type script and flow types will
not pass
okay this parsing so we can always
surround them with a parenthesis and it
works by the way i checked when i was
writing the proposal any type in
typescript and flow you can just add
parentheses and they still work
so as i said some typescript will need
to be rewritten to accommodate this but
very very slow so we were talking about
functions variables the the type of the
variable
types where you can define aliases for
example this pair
a pair type
interface just like in typescript
i've never understood why there's both
interface and type but whatever
class properties just like in typescript
and flow generics very important i think
this is important uh today a language
without generics is not really there
import and exporting types that's
possible we've also added it
uh but there are some that are
problematic and we we don't really know
how to deal with that and we'll flesh it
out
during
the stage two
uh casting casting in flow is the not
low flow sorry
that's the bottom one and the top one is
typescript as something we need to
figure out we incorporate both of them
we incorporate one
i'm all for the top one not because i
like typescript because i think it's
easier to explain
generic function invocations this is
valid typescript is not valid javascript
by the way because uh
type javascript will look at it as like
do something is less than number and
it's also bigger than blah blah blah
blah blah this is not and type and
typescript knows that and they are
willing to change typescript
for example adding the double call on
there they are willing to change
typescript to accommodate this to be
okay this is this is a
please for the typescript teams
i feel like they're part of the
community the typescript and flow teams
are part of the community and they're
all there for the community
this parameters it collides with another
proposal that is in t39
declarations actually there you can't
put it in a ts file you have to put it
in a dts file uh but some people are
talking about that function overloads
that's a big problem how do you deal
with that a function without a body oh i
don't know what to do with that
abstract classes
that has semantics that maybe have run
time semantics so what do we do with
that
and member modifiers they're just stuck
in the middle of the class declaration
like they're ugly what if we want to add
uh
typescript and we have suggested maybe
adding a sigil sigil sigil to them like
percent public and then we javascript
just ignores whatever is after the
percent
things that will not be in the spec
enums namespaces parameter properties
jsx why are they not there because
they're not just type annotations they
write code
an enum is code for for for us an object
if you if you think namespaces also
create objects they will not be part of
the spec but anyway typescript says
please stop using that that was a
mistake
the consequence if this proposal lands
no more transpilation no more need of
transportation of most typescript and
flow and if we use real browser esm we
will finally remove all tooling will
still be checked by types
well by third-party types there will be
slow convergence of incompatible
typescript and flow to this proposal
tooling will become much simpler
other type systems hopefully will be
experimented with
but it will take time
it will take
years
but i hope this proposal ends it will be
worth the wait thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you